your accent there is great and dairy
girls yeah i mean there's a whole range
of accents yours is really good oh thank
you
would you say there's a whole range of
accents in very good a few dairy accents
in very girls i would say yeah but now
do you you have a trick to get into it
do you yeah absolutely so when i was
preparing i didn't know a dairy accent
first off and then i thought who do i
know and then i thought oh nadine from
girls aloud is extremely dairy and then
i don't know if people will know this
but there was an extremely controversial
incident
in the early 90s in ireland so good it
was so good well i feel like it was the
first irish sort of pop culture tv
moment it was pop stars the irish
version which only had about 50 entrants
because we don't have as big a
population
so she went on and lied about her age
but she got found out on camera stop it
yes
youtube it's so good
okay so she's gotten into the band and
then her on camera interview like the
first one to introduce yourself who you
are she said my damn sadine coiler from
larkil and larry the other birth 15th
the 685 mecca me and germany and then
she thinks for a second and goes
what date of birth did i say you know
fifteen to the second and then it fades
and she's she's she's outed herself on
camera but everyone lost the plot
do the phone call to her mother
mommy do the whole thing daddy put my
passport in the car mommy will you look
at my handbag for my passport and it was
all a lie she knew
she was 16 she was meant to be 18.
what is it about you lot pretending
you're different ages
cool isn't it because she wanted to make
it through that's but then but then she
got and girls allowed it actually worked
out much better you see yeah yeah
and we ended up with an amazing moment
of her sobbing in the back of a renault
spas being driven away
i
also did that whole thing in my audition
and it was very awkward because you did
it as a speech yeah but they didn't want
me to it's not like they said would you
mind doing your pre-preparedness
speech i just sort of started speaking
and they sort of were looking at me and
i thought well this could really go
either way you know it's all the
executives from channel 4 and the
director and the writer and i just
started doing it but i got the job it's
all fine
very good
it's a different experience going you
know being an actor yeah it's very
different than this so was it a big kind
of
shock to you or do you find it easy
no uh i i found it really weird i still
find it really weird i mean essentially
it it happened for such a weird reason
as well um i
and the rest of the girls we did uh bake
off uh a celebrity
version of it and i had a nervous
breakdown on it and they thought
i think she'll do well in our pottery
show
how intense is it in that bloody tent uh
for bake off it's so intense oh it's
good i cried i've never cried over a
cake oh my god good almighty it it's
it's it's just it's really intense and
you're like who cares it's a bloody cake
it's a sponge i'm an actor and you end
up having a nervous breakdown you cried
yeah i cried i mean i mean you when you
watch it on the telly oh get over
yourself why are you crying but i know
then i was like when you're ready
yeah you're like what is
i don't have post-traumatic stress
disorder here but let's have a look at
your cake so this is the cake
so this is your what was your cake
called irish camping holiday
is that new york look
yeah it was it was it was basically it
was a decade cake wasn't this for
charities i mean to roll with the
punches
look at that so is that the ocean yes
and that's the grass yes and the yellow
bit is the sand and that's the that's
the sand what's the big cack on the top
it's a tent
oh okay not a chocolate tent why did you
choose brown
i've no no booty i know yeah
the next big
[Laughter]
here's alan's cake
what is that
it's the ladder
he's asleep he's asleep and it's a
rainbow dream cake that's what we were
told oh
he's asleep yes but it looks like i've
fallen off the ladder
and
also i've done if you experienced this
but everyone who cooked because it's
long hours isn't it all the camera crew
are there very hard and everyone leaves
the cake
on the side so the crew can nibble away
and maybe have a slice
mine was intact
you know what i might have a little bit
of a bungle on top no no
[Music]